Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to "Slayaway Camp."
"They thought summer camp would be fun.."
No...
"It wasn't long before they realized..."
Mmmm...
"It would be deadly."
Oh no..
"Slayaway Camp'
Yes...the game where you are the murder and you have to ...
i don't know, annihilate these poor people that are just trying to have a fun time at camp.
Either way, it's just a big bag of dickatry, buuuut...
Before I even get started in the game I wanted to mention something about the game options menu.
And you may be thinking to yourself like...
"WHOA, MARK."
"We know you're scraping the bottom of the barrel of creativity here, but you're really just gonna show us a game menu?"
Hang on.
Hold off on those...
On those messages of hate you're typing up right now.
I just... I thought this was funny.
'cause, I was playing around with the options like I always do...
and then there's a sliders button.
And the more you do the sliders
the more options there are.
And I don't know.
I--I found it funny.
They had "Embloodening".
"Increase the level of blood splishoshity"?
*Stutters* "Boneism"?
"Adjust  level of bone chunk madness"?
I don't even know what this is.
"Feel the view"?
MY GOD.
The fuck just happened to it?
Yay, field? Y--yay--naw. Full field.
I guess. "Bolometric Do--" I dunno...
"Call upon the bark of the wild for maximum immersion."
Ok.
Shh.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh, jeeze, what have I done?
"Shhmalumetricfrog."
"Adjust the fraction of space/time in which frogs exist in an alternate dimension."
Ok.
"Quad reception:Adjust the levels in which quadrinions quad ricept through the innermost velocities."
"Dark Suspicions: *In between laughter* You don't like the look of this slider.*
Alright, ok.
"Beer gut Phys. Enhance:  increases gel-modled jiggle dynamics."
Oh--oh jeeze, I was just about to say
"Hopefully that applies to boobs"but there's...
"Boobs" right here as well.
"Adjust-- increases your  anime collection's size."
*Sniff*I don't have any animes.
"Jowl Physics: Uses real time flab rendering algarhythms
Oh, ok.
"Hidden Space Embigganing:  Increase--"
"...if your hidden surfaces are too microlit--"
I don't know what that means.
"Erradicate your progress and begining  a new as a fresh soul of psycho-killer born from the darkness."
Aah, I just started, I have no idea how to play.
Whaa--I dunno how to play!
OOOH JEEZE.
Oh, God!
I'm sorry, children!
That is a lot of embloodening.
*Chuckling*And that is a lot of embonening.
Oh, jeeze *laughing*
Just the way he slaps into the walls.
That's a murderer for ya.
Alright.
"Slide and kill the camp safety officer."
Oh, ok.
Good thing there are footprints to know exactly where I need to
GO!
OH.
Oh, jeeze *Laughing.
That's a little horrifying.
I guess that's the point.
GOODBYE.
Alrighty, then.
So, yeah, this is what the game's about. It's like a...
It's like a delightful puzzle murder game.
Uh...
Which is, you know.The best. "SLAUGHTER THE TEENAGERS!"
What could be better in a game?
And that God damn dog.
Needs to stop barking all the place.
Ok, so if I--
If I spoop one of these...
Is it gonna spoop all of them?
Ha-DAH!
Uh-oh.
Oooh, jeeze. *Laughing*
Aah, it's really horrifying.
Oh, man-- Sorry.
Oh, jeeze. Honestly, I... I dunno how I fee about this. At least the bunnies are ok. The adorable little bunnies over there, they're gonna be just fine.
They're not gonna get embloddened.
"Bonus kill:click when the skull is in the red  zone"?
In the kill zone.
Oh, God.
WELP.
I got it!
I got bonus kill coins!
Great!
Whyy? Is this supposed to be an ap?
"See how they run."
I dunno if I wanna see how they run.
HUAH! Oh, jeeze,I headbutted him into oblivion.
Oh, boy.
Ha-BOOSHKY *Laughing*
Ah, jeeze.
I'm such a horrible person, but I guess I'm a murderer, so what does it matter?
Oh, jeeze...
Alrighty, then.
Well, I'm doing wonderfully.
Hope you all are having a good day.
"Murder scares other people."
Yeah!I  would imagine that!
Ha-BLEH.
Aaah!
Oh, no, so scared, are ya?
Well, too bad, you're about to be...
Uuuhhh...
Hang on. Oh, ok, I know wha...Yeah!
Yeah! Hah!
Oooh, God, oh no!
What are you gonna do to me?!
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?!
OH, YOU'RE GONNA MURDER ME?! AAAAAH!
And now he's dead. And he got exploded.
Is that, like, supposed to be...
the--the Jason Voorhee --OOOOHHHH.
OOOH MY GOOOD.
The amount of blood might be too embloodened.
"Sequential Slice."
Ooh.
Alright.
Ha-boosky?
Ha-boosky...?
Oh, jeeze.
Oh, jeeze,
Wait, how am I gonna get out of here?
Uh- oh.
Uh-oh. UH-OH.
UH-OOH.
Uh-OOOHH. So, what I need to do is...
I need to not kill that guy first.
Oh, that's--
UUAAAAGH
We got a conundrum here.
Yeah, I'm gonna turn off that dog bark
God, dammit.
The Bolumetric Dog was just too much.
Ok...
Oooh.
That's handy.
Aah, ok,  I got it. Ok.
FUBADOOSKY!
Kill zone.
Sorry.
Apparently that murder was amazing.
"El Fuego De La Muerte."
The fire of the death? The--the death fire? The fire...the fire of the death?
We gotta be tactical about this, because I wanna murder correctly.
Does this mean that I can't--
Ha-boosky.
OH.
GOD.
If I'd had know stepping into a camp fire would do that HOLY SHIT! I'm never going camping again!
Alrighty, then. Well, neither of these guy--OH.
What happens if I go?
AAAAAAAAAAH!
*Fart noise.*
Ok. Ha-boosky.
Sorry...
Sorry about that.
Sorry, guys. I'm terribly so--oh.
WHAT--DID I PUNCH HIS HEAD OFF?!
DID I JUST-- *Punching noises*
--PUNCH HIS HEAD CLEAN OFF?!
"Ticki Trickery."
Ok.
I don't know what that means.
BOO!
Ah, I guess you're not scared, huh?
Ha-BOO!
HA-BOO!
Oooh, but I can't go there, I'll die. Aaah, I see.
*Mark noises.*
Hellooooo.
Aaaaaaah! That's how you do it! I got it, ok.
I like this, by the way. Besides all the murder--
I ripped his heart out.
I ripped his heart out. But I mean, between the murder--
"Kill Cunt Down:Finish in six turns." Or else the police are gonna come get me.
WELL.
Alrighty, then. But I mean, it's--it's the mixture of murder with, like, the cutesy art style that really makes it for me.
Ha-boosky.
Alright. *more Mark noises.*
Shit.
Awww, no, they got me!
Wait, no. Wait, what am I, an idiot?
What, am I? Stupid?
Like that!
Why am I so dumb?
Eh.
Oh, you want a--what can I only assume is a a pumpkin based on the sign behind you?
OH, JEEZE.
If I'd had know pumpkins were that dangerous I never would have smashed them! "Final Scene."
"A Hole..."
"A hole" what?
A "hole" load of murder? What happens if I go in the hole?
Hello.
AAAAA. Ok. Well...
If I'm only six feet under it doesn't... mean that's too bad.
Hello!
UAH!
UH-OH!
Ooh.
GEEZUM.
HOLY BALLS.
"First Movie:Complete." YAY!
We got a movie done!
Oh, my God.
"Welcome to the video store. Click on the shop buttons and I'll show you something."
Ok...
Shop!
"This is the shop. Here's 1000 coins! click a gore pack (Random special kill!) to unlock it!"
OH.
Oh, I could get "Spronged"?
"Broken Hearted. Eff the Bonus."
"Double Blind."
*laughing* "Face Stapled."
"Charbroiled, Demonized, Juiced, No-- NOT THE BEES."
I want "Not the Bees." Oh, God, I want 'Not the Bees."
AUGH. BEES.
"One bumblebee is kind of cute. A whole bunch is skill kind of cute, but they also might kill you." Great!
"Here are your unlocked gore packs. Go to the killer shelf now for some fun."
"Unlock killers by playing movies, or use the mystery box for a surprise once you've saved up enough skull coins."
"Now return to the movie shelf."
Ok... "A new movie came in! Click on it to start slaying."
Oh, JEEZE.
"Return to Slayaway Camp"
They thought it was ok to go back to camp, but...
They're STUPID.
And it wasn't. Why would they go back?
YEAH, IT WASN'T.
Oh.
"Maskless Skullface"
Ew, gross! Don't look at him, he's really gross!
Oh,God, I love this game!
This game is amazing!
I love everything about this game!
"Scene one: A really dumb cop." Oh, my Goodness Gracious.
Oh, my God. Ok, um... I actually want to do more of this
I want to do more episodes of this. This is a really cool game.
It's something like--on the surface it looks so but the--the humor of it and the silliness of it and like
the GORINESS of it. Juck supposed by the cuteness of it. It's just really interesting to me and I love it a lot like
It's really fun. Even though it's like a simple puzzle that's been done before, it's done in such a charming way.
Also, will this kill me?
Well, Jesus. Just because I was ugly doesn't mean he had to kill me for it!
Oh, Well...
Oh.
Well.
Alright, then.
There we go--Santa???
"Played by Rachel Ebens"?
Oh, jeeze.
Oh, that's awesome.
Oh, I love that! It's so good.
Oh, it's all, like, movie based!
Aw, it's all like movie...
Aw, it's so cool.
Alright, anyway.So, that's all I'm going to do for this one. But I am gonna do another episode of this very soon, so...
Let me know what you think of this game down in the comments below. And thank you everybody for watching.
And as always I will see you... in the next video. Bye bye!